bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
session à d'informations voici tout
d'abord ce que l'on peut retenir en ce
jeudi 18 juin un métro enterré sous les
habitations du quartier de la
bretonnière à voisins le bretonneux
le projet surprise de la ligne 18 du
grand parent est loin de faire
l'unanimité
la mairie monte au créneau dirty corner
l'oeuvre emblématique de l'artiste anish
kapoor exposé à versailles vandalisés et
de la peinture jour n'a été déversé à
l'intérieur 59% des moins de 24 mois
sont vaccinés c'est loin des 80 %
souhaitée par le gouvernement
une campagne de sensibilisation à la
vaccination va être lancée par la caisse
primaire d'assurance maladie des
yvelines
mais nous démarrons tout de suite en ce
18 juin par la cérémonie d'hommage à
l'appel lancé un certain es 10 juin 1940
par le général de gaulle depuis londres
un appel à la mobilisation aujourd'hui
c'était donc le 75e anniversaire de cet
appel des commémorations ont eu lieu un
peu partout en france comme ici à bois
d'arcy en présence du maire et des
anciens combattants qui ont pour
l'occasion relu à l'appel de l'époque
puis observé une minute de silence
c'est très important les commémorations
citoyens d'abord parce qu'on applique
les jeunes dans nos commémoration pour
transmettre le devoir de mémoire c'est
très importante pas oublier c'est très
important de commémorer nos grands faits
historiques et transmettent ce devoir de
mémoire qui est impérieux pour pouvoir
mieux préparer l'avenir et se souvenir
du passé il avait tout compris en rouge
à 40 pouces hull
condamné à mort il avait compris que le
combat devait continuer et que rien
n'était perdu et qu'il y avait toujours
une lueur d'espoir et que la flamme de
la résistance ne vais pas s'éteindre et
c'est ça le caractère visionnaire du
général de gaulle et je suis gaulliste
depuis le début alors vous savez ça me
plaît quand même plaisir que ce soit
fait au moins dans la ville le plaisir
de voir qu'il y avait quelqu'un qui
voulait battre pour la france ce
mercredi matin des agents du domaine du
château de versailles ont remarqué des
jets de peinture jaune sur une des
oeuvres d'anish kapoor jugé sexuelle par
ses détracteurs dirty corner surnommé
par son créateur le vagin de la reine un
tube d'acier de 60 mètres de long avait
fait polémique dès son arrivée dans les
jardins du château certains ont
considéré l'oeuvre inappropriée et une
pétition pour son retrait a déjà
collecté plus de onze mille deux cents
signatures
l'artiste anglais d'origine indienne a
réagi ce matin vandalisme chez nos
confrères du figaro
quelle tragédie quelle tristesse at il
dit j'espère qu'il ne s'agit que d'un
groupuscule dont la voix recoupent
celles de la plupart des autres je
trouve ce phénomène de nuisance triste a
donc dit anish kapoor
le château de versailles n'a pas
souhaité apporter de commentaire l'étude
des caméras de vidéosurveillance
pourraient permettre d'en savoir plus et
que pensez vous justement de la
vandalisation de l'oeuvre d'anish kapoor
c'est notre question du jour
bon je trouve ça dommage de vandaliser
des oeuvres d'art
quelles que soient les goûts qu'on est
en art faut déjà savoir que c'est un
vagin moi je les ai vus à la télé cette
culture il n'y a vraiment pas besoin de
la bande alizés parce qu'en plus ça
ressemble même pas on s'aime pas à quoi
ressemble faut pas banaliser ces
fraudeurs même si ça fait polémique à
cause de du nom que sa porte c'est pas
bien pour l'artiste puisqu'il n'a pas
fait ça pour pour choquer les personnes
en plus c'est l'artiste qui les a pour
nous pour qu'on puisse voir de nouvelles
choses des oeuvres donc
il faut respecter le travail des autres
ouais c'est un acte honteux 1
clairement je trouve ça absolument pas
normal ça rappelle un peu ce qui s'est
passé à bordeaux rappelle dans un musée
ou et des gens qui rentraient pour
taillader des oeuvres je comprends pas
ces choses-là la culture il faut la
respecter c'est très important c'est une
partie du patrimoine et à ce titre là je
pense que c'est un problème d'éducation
de j'imagine des gens qui respectent pas
les oeuvres d'art qui comprennent pas la
valeur que ça un métro sous les
habitations du quartier de la
bretonnière voisins le bretonneux c'est
le tracé surprise de la société du grand
paris pour le passage de la ligne 18 à
aucun moment la ville n'a été concerté
sur ce dossier et les élus montent au
créneau
explications pas s'en plaindre les
habitations un métro enterré sous le
quartier de la bretonnière à voisins le
bretonneux la mauvaise surprise
découverte il ya quelques jours par la
mary dei de la commune
le hic la ville n'a jamais été concertés
sur cette question et pour cause le
tracé de la ligne 18 qui doit relier
orly à versailles ne devait pas
concerner la commune
c'est la première fois que ce tracé
dirait apparaît à aucun moment
auparavant voisin n'a été impactée par
le tracé du métro et ce nouveau tracé
est sorti le 15 avril c'est à dire entre
les deux tours de l'élection municipale
à voisins ce qui fait que je n'ai pas
été informé à ce moment là alexandra
rosetti a rencontré cette semaine la
société du grand paris en charge du
projet de ce métro automatique
l'élu se dit confiante quant à la
modification du périmètre en raison
notamment d'un problème de qualité de
sol une étude a été demandée dont les
conclusions pourraient être connus au
mois d'octobre
c'est un sol argileux en a des maisons
qui ont été renforcées par des
micropieux on dépose un dossier de
catastrophe naturelle va cela beaucoup
de fissures même notre maison de
quartier est extrêmement fissurer donc
ça semble difficile de creuser même même
très profond alexandra rosetti va
solliciter le soutien de la casse qui
est du conseil départemental
si les discussions avec la société du
grand paris n'aboutissent pas un recours
est possible
là il ya eu un loupé et je pense même
que j'aurais dit
ans
c'est un petit peu limite et peut-être
qu'ils se rendent compte aussi que je
peux je peux momie opposés parce que les
choses n'ont pas été faites dans les
règles
une réunion d'information avec les
habitants du quartier de la bretonnière
aura lieu fin juin
en ce début de période du ramadan le
préfet d idée d'installer le 6000
conseil des institutions musulmanes des
yvelines
une première en france une première
réunion solennelle pour installer le
6000 conseil des institutions musulmanes
des yvelines une volonté de ces
associations cultuelles qui fait suite à
une circulaire du 11 mars du premier
ministre manuel valls après les
dramatiques événements de janvier ceci
me devrait se réunir une fois par mois
et une fois par trimestre en présence du
préfet différents thèmes pourront être
abordés comme les lieux de culte
l'organisation de l'aïd et les actions
entre islam et citoyenneté de
concertation et ensuite je salue jamais
de juger certaines manières de des gens
de poser les problèmes et d'apporter du
soutien des solutions de plus approprié
des fois les élus locaux sont devant
certains passent par rapport à des
situations plus d'argent propre et donc
là de chimie apporte ça continue de sa
contribution
c'est à dire dans le style avec une
forme de confiance dual view qui permet
de prendre des décisions qui sont pas
simples à prendre
comment on peut apporter des réponses
dans le cadre encore une fois de la
république et des lois et règlements en
vigueur donc il s'agit pas de se
substituer aux associations mais de les
accompagner de faire en sorte que leur
projet dès lors qu'ils ont les moyens de
les réaliser ne soit pas bloquée ou une
subissent pas d'avatar tels que espace
réalisme concrètement c'est par exemple
comment résoudre la problématique posée
à guyancourt par la demande des
associations d'obtenir un autre lieu de
culte
nous avons demandé aux représentants du
simi de devenir venir faire une
médiation entre les associations et et
de nous aider à construire une solution
pérenne pour l'avenir
la préfecture des yvelines a répertorié
dans le département 70 de culte ce sont
autant d'associations cultuelles dont
une trentaine de mosquées et puis sachez
que le ramadan la période de jeunes a
démarré officiellement ce jeudi à 4
heures du mat
1 comme les années précédentes un
dispositif d'abattoirs mobile a été mis
en place sur la commune d'hallencourt
d'ailleurs le seul abattoir dans le
département allez santé pour continuer
le refus de soins défi pour les équipes
mobiles de psychiatrie du sujet âgé
un sujet tabou dont on ne parle pas
facilement il en était question à
l'occasion d'un colloque qui s'est
déroulée aujourd'hui à plaisir on va
essayer d'y voir un peu plus clair avec
nos invités dr valéry à véronique mala
bonsoir vous êtes responsable de l'unité
s mac et l'équipe mobile du sujet âgé
rattaché à l'hôpital charcot de plaisir
et marquer bozon bonsoir vous êtes
infirmière au sein de cette même unité
d'abord première question sur une unité
mobile sur le sujet âgé comment ça
fonctionne et à quoi ça sert alors
l'équipe a été créé en 2013 grâce au
soutien de l'hôpital charcot à plaisir
et du réseau santé mentale sud yvelines
et grâce au soutien du conseil général
et brs
nous travaillons à la demande des
professionnels pour pouvoir aller au
domicile évaluer les personnes les plus
vulnérables ce sont les personnes âgées
qui présentent d'étranges le psychiatre
a dû vous demander qu'est ce qu'une
personne âgée ya un début d'âge pour la
personne
c'est une question un peu délicate sa
force à nous nous avons fixé 60 ans
parce que la population des personnes
que nous soignons
en santé mentale et souvent souvent à un
âge plus avancé au niveau somatique
donc c'est important de les prendre en
charge pour quelles sont les pathologies
alors on pense évidemment un santé
mentale aux personnes âgées on pense
alzheimer parce qu'on en parle beaucoup
d'alzheimer mais quels sont les autres
pathologies appac a dreamer loin de là
donc l'idée c'est de d'aller vraiment au
plus près de la souffrance psychique
de la personne âgée qui n'accèdent pas
aux soins facilement donc on va
s'occuper de toute pathologie ça peut
être la dépression avec des idées
suicidaires mais ça peut être des
pathologies psychiatriques plus
anciennes qui ne sont plus pris en
charge
donc c'est très vaste et très variée
maintenant vous êtes sur le terrain avec
l'équipe
d'abord comment se fait le premier
contact est ce que ce sont les familles
qui vous appelle est ce que c'est la
personne âgée qui fait appel à vous ou
est ce que c'est le médecin généraliste
ou une coordination gérontologique des
professionnels qui nous appellent donc
ça peut être soit le médecin généraliste
soit un médecin gériatre soit le sujet l
on travaille beaucoup et et coordination
gérontologique locale soit un psychiatre
sa femme psychiatre libéral qui aurait
besoin qu'on prenne en charge pour un
temps donné à domicile des personnes
comment vous intervenez ce que vous
allez directement domicile vous êtes
hockey la porte des gens dès que vous
avez des comptes et vous savez qu'un cas
est avéré ou quand même vous prenez
contact avec la personne avant pour
établir un dialogue avec elle prend
d'abord contact en fête avec tous les
professionnels concernés autour de la
personne âgée qu'on prend contact avec
tous les professionnels que je viens de
nommer un toit en table pour le médecin
généraliste parce qu'en général c'est
l'huile puis le pilier de la prise en
charge et c'est lui qu'il connaît bien
en fait la personne âgée qu'on s'adresse
d'abord à lui pour voir un petit peu ce
qu'ils en pensent savoir s'il est
d'accord avec le fait qu'on aime ou pas
et puis donc on discute beaucoup en fait
déjà de cet aspect là ensuite on peut
prendre contact avec les cgl pour savoir
s'ils suivent cette personne et une fois
qu'on a pris contact en fait avec la
famille on prend aussi contact avec la
famille et après parfois on prend
contact dont il ya le cgl et puis
ensuite on s'adresse à la personne on va
l'appeler soit nous donc soit le médecin
généraliste en général c'est quand même
le médecin généraliste qui va prend
contact avec la personne âgée qui va lui
expliquer que nous allons venir qui nous
sommes et pourquoi
et puis si la personne va décider s'il
accepte ou pas ouais parce que c'est
compliqué d'intervenir à quel moment on
peut intervenir on peut dire bah si vous
monsieur vous n'êtes pas très bien on
intervient pour vous aider et aussi le
libre choix de la personne de vouloir
être aidés ou qu'en juin
voilà oui tout à fait donc c'est pour ça
que c'est tout ce travail en amont donc
par martin rozon est très important
puisque ça va permettre de créer
l'alliance et de pouvoir se mettre
d'accord sur l'intervention est que la
personne puisse nous recevoir
puisque c'est comme une invitation c'est
pas une obligation
j'ai d'années qui refuse un de nous voir
aussi assez souvent
non non non c'est très bien à quoi ils
se sentent soulagés entre guillemets cas
d'un seul coup on s'intéresse peut-être
à eux oui oui tout à fait et ils sont
contents qu'ils autant de personnes qui
se mobilisent pour aller chez le vert et
pour comprendre ce qui se passe pour je
réponds parle d'un problème peut-être
que j'ai découvert autour des personnes
âgées qu'ils prennent des hallucinations
les personnes âgées sont souvent sujets
à des hallucinations il reste des
caractéristiques identiques et en tout
cas elles vont avoir une propension à
avoir des hallucinations beaucoup plus
facilement que la population générale
donc une dépression peut tout à fait se
se montrer à pas avec des symptômes
hallucinatoire ce qui n'est pas
forcément le cas fils la personne plus
jeune je veux aussi un mot sur la
solitude
on évoque peut-être pas assez souvent la
solitude de la personne âgée
voilà ils reçoivent de temps en temps un
coup de fil on vient les voir mais
souvent elles se sentent un peu seuls
c'est un vraie problématique des loyers
le oui oui tout à fait c'est une des
leçons veufs ou veuves oui tout à fait
et de deux oui tout à fait c'est quand
les gens effectivement il ya le décès du
mari ou de la femme effectivement les
patients se sentent y en a qui le gère
bien et il y en ad'autres chez qui sont
en train de cette politique entraîne un
état dépressif
parce qu'ils ont l'habitude depuis 50 60
ans de vivre avec quelqu'un et du jour
au lendemain ils se retrouvent seuls
chez eux
effectivement cette solitude peut être
très lourde à porter il faut dire quand
même que aujourd'hui dans notre société
les personnages y sont quand même très
saine plus seuls 40 parce que le noyau
familial c'est un peu plus éclaté dans
le top des vieux poncifs de dire
vivement c'est un peu comme comment
quels conseils justement on peut donner
aux familles qui elles sont proches de
personnes âgées où habitent en province
on ne les voit pas souvent
comment on peut réagir quels sont les
signaux d alerte sur une personne âgée
qui aurait des troubles des petits
troubles psychologiques ou
psychiatriques une perte d'appétit
par exemple tout ce qui change
d'habitude de l'habitude en tout cas
peut être un signe d' alerte et il faut
surtout que les familles n'hésitent pas
à appeler le médecin traitant
accompagner la personne en consultation
pour discuter évoquer leurs inquiétudes
il ya une première réunion jeudi qu'a eu
lieu une première rencontre qui a eu
aujourd'hui à plaisir avec tous les
établissements d'île de france autour de
cette problématique du refus des soins
c'est important comme ça de vous
rencontrer entre vous autres
établissements franciliens pour échanger
les bonnes pratiques
alors c'est vrai que c'était important
parce qu'il ya de nombreuses équipes
mobiles psychiatrique du sujet âgé
en ile de france on a repéré qu on
fonctionnait très différemment
et ça nous a semblé évident de pouvoir
se rencontrer faire connaissance et
surtout échanger sur nos pratiques
justement est-ce que vous avez des
bonnes pratiques des pratiques
différentes que vous avez observé sur
intéressante à mettre en place des
pratiques différentes 1 entre notre
magna par exemple ce qu'on a pu observer
aujourd'hui c'est par exemple bron au
niveau de la temporalité les
temporalités entre les différentes
équipes qui étaient présentes sont
différentes nous on peut dans port à
l'itc le temps de alors soit le temps
pour le temps de réaction que l'on
m'aide pour aller visiter la personne
est peut-être plus ou moins longues en
fonction des équipes y en a qui
réagissent en fait qu'ils prennent qui
réagissent dans les 24 heures dans les
70's 72 heures et nous ont très peu
mettre une semaine ça dépend enfin de
beaucoup de parents fait beaucoup de
choses vous réagissez plus en une
semaine ça peut être des plus rapides ça
dépend ça dépendra dé revenir rapidement
de nos disponibilités mais on n'est pas
une équipe d'urgence par contre ta
l'équipe d'urgence et le groupe g le
trait qui peuvent être des équipes
d'urgence du coup il ya la soirée de
dimanche dépend de vous êtes combien au
sein de votre unité mobile je vous ai
pas demandé et qui la composent il ya
trois infirmières et puis un temps
médicale composée de deux médecins et
donc un point le bilan sur cette journée
positif que très peu intime on tente en
tout cas ça a permis de voir que le
consensus c'est qu'on est tous ensemble
à prendre soin d'eux et et qu' on est
attentif au respect
la liberté la contrainte des questions
là autour du refus de soins ont été
abordés et voilà c'est assez important
qu'on puisse repérer que on est tous
confrontés aux mêmes difficultés finale
et puis avoir ouvert bien attention à
nos personnes âgées merci beaucoup à
vous d'être venu sur le plateau du
journal nous allons rester dans le
domaine de la santé mais la santé des
tout-petits puisqu'on va parler
vaccination la caisse primaire
d'assurance maladie des yvelines
rappelle l'importance donc de la
vaccination des bébés une vaccination
qui doit être fait à temps pour être
efficace c'est le message de leurs
campagnes de prévention qui sera lancé
dès la rentrée
yolaine torres pour les explications
pour protéger votre enfant vacciné le
attend c'est le message de la caisse
primaire d'assurance maladie des
yvelines la vaccination petite enfance
comme véritable enjeu de santé publique
à la rentrée l'organisme lancera une
campagne sur l'ensemble du département
où la situation est plutôt contrasté
on peut dire qu'elle est globalement
assez comparable au niveau national mais
par contre nous sommes assez nettement
en retrait par rapport aux
recommandations du calendrier vaccinal
c'est à dire que les enfants sont
inclinés mais ils sont vaccinés souvent
avec retard
à titre d'exemple 59 % des moins de 24
mois sont à jour de leurs vaccins
hépatite b
loin des 80 % souhaité par l'état un
retard qui s'explique peut-être par la
méconnaissance de certains parents du
calendrier vaccinal
au cours de ses deux premières années un
enfant est beaucoup plus vulnérables à
certaines maladies telles que la
rougeole la coqueluche
aujourd'hui on recommande de débuter
avec station l'âge de 2 mois avec un
vaccin hexavalent qui comprend la
diphtérie le tétanos la poliomyélite
poliomyélite et l'haemophilus qui sont
un agent d'un de méningite coqueluche
hépatite b et le même jour on pratique
dans l'autre cuisse du bébé le vaccin
contre le pneumocoque qui est un agent
infectieux qui donne des méningites
sévère chez les tout petits ont commencé
à l'âge de deux mois
fa la deuxième dose à l'âge de 4 mois et
un rappel à 11 mois autre raison
possible de la situation contrastée dans
les yvelines la réticence des parents
certains sont inquiets et se demandent
par exemple si le système immunitaire de
leurs enfants est assez mature pour
pouvoir répondre au vaccin
je leur explique que le système
immunitaire de leurs enfants et
stimuler de manière extrêmement précoce
par de nombreux virus bactéries qui sont
dans l'air sans la peau du bébé dans ses
intestins et que le vaccin représente
une toute petite simulation immunitaire
qui va être extrêmement bien toléré par
leurs excès la campagne de prévention
pour la vaccination des tout petits se
poursuivra jusqu'à la fin de l'année
elle sera relayée par les médecins et
pharmaciens tandis que les parents
seront sensibilisés par courrier ou sms
et le poursuivant ce journal avec le 16e
championnat inter collèges de match
d'improvisation réalisé par la compagnie
déclic théâtre les finales se sont
déroulées à la merise de trappes quatre
collèges étaient concernés que les jeux
courbet et le village attrape alexandre
dumas à maurepas et albert einstein à
magny les hameaux
c'est toujours une réussite
effectivement c'est bien d'une part aux
partenaires qui nous aident depuis de
très nombreuses années s'est dit aussi à
l'activité des collègues donc qu
enseignant qui font un boulot énorme
et puis c'était aussi à des qit théâtre
suisse air de pouvoir le dire la un
championnat avec une formule qui a fait
ses preuves avant de passer dans la
patinoire les jeunes de quatre collèges
de l'agglomération découvre les thèmes
imposés par l' arbitre un arbitre
exigeant qui distribue bons et mauvais
points
le public et lui invité à voter pour
choisir la meilleure prestation
les collégiens ont été bien formé par
leur coach c'était assez stressé mais du
coup on a on a privilégié le fait que
c'était une rencontre plus qu'une finale
puisqu'un match et du coup ils se sont
détendus au fur et à mesure ils ont ils
ont réussi à créer le partage dans les
improvisations dans l'imaginaire et du
coup bah voilà ils ont su montrer leur
talent dans la patinoire avec les autres
et pas contre les autres en finale le
collège le village l'emportent face à
l'équipe d'albert einstein de magny les
hameaux des étoiles ont aussi récompensé
les meilleurs joueurs de manière
individuelle
ça se sera passé on a bien joué il
malgré des petites tensions parce que
voilà avant tout ses spectacles à du
monde 300 personnes un peu le trac et
tout ça mais sinon globalement celle ci
doit passer qu'est ce que tu vas retenir
toi qu'est ce que tu veux retenir de
cette finale
mais à part la victoire est la victoire
c'était génial on peut décide pas avoir
gagné mais c'est quand même bien d'être
arrivé deuxième alors qu'est ce que tu
as retiendra de cette soirée il y avait
des peines improvisation comme louis a
été très belle improvisation est bon on
avait des très bons adversaires en phase
donc je suis pas étonné qu'ils aient
gagné mais j'espère qu'on gagnera même
prochaine donc toi c'est déjà là les
prochaines à rendez-vous en 2016
ouais c'est ça et c'est benoît hamon le
député socialiste de la 11e
circonscription de trappes qui a remis
le premier prix à l'équipe gagnante
qui s'est construit imaginer attrape ya
maintenant c'est le 16e championnat
intercollèges va être déployé dans
l'éducation nationale dans le cadre de
la réforme des rythmes scolaires chez
les tout-petits donc en primaire ce qui
montre que on a compris qu'avec ce genre
de prestation là et des gamins qui
pouvait avoir des difficultés dans les
cours classiques qui déverrouille des
choses par le théâtre par
l'improvisation une soirée aussi bien
techniques que divertissante sur fond de
haut précisent ical et d'éclats de rires
et puis encore bravo à l'équipe du
collège le village qui a remporté donc
ce championnat championnat qu'on pourra
retrouver dans son intégralité sur notre
antenne dès cet été
et puis nous terminons ce journal par
une exposition celle de rennes-ii
maillard à rambouillet le palais du roi
de rome consacre donc une exposition à
l'art de la laque à savoir faire
ancestral qui devient de plus en plus
rares
spécialiste de la laque de chine depuis
35 ans et ancien styliste pour de grands
noms de la mode
raimu mayen expose ses peintures et
sculptures aux baleines du roi de rome à
rambouillet
mais des corps ont évolué par rapport à
la haute couture
bien sûr qu'on ressent des réminiscences
les kimonos en son expression j'aimais
beaucoup les étoffes j'aimais beaucoup
la soie mais lorsque j'ai découvert la
lacc
c'est à travers le lac je me suis
exprimé une grande créativité qui fait
voyager les visiteurs dans une technique
ancestrale issus de métiers existants en
chine et au japon depuis des millénaires
ces procédés et son art ont beaucoup
évolué en ce qui concerne donc les les
bases ou les supports qui sont utilisés
dans la laque
traditionnellement c'est surtout le bois
qui est préférée chez les lakers est un
matériau qu'on peut transformer l on
peut sculpter que l'on peut façonner
j'utilise aussi c'est de la fibre de
verre depuis quelques années parce que
la fibre de verre pourquoi parce qu'elle
est très légère rémy maillard incruste
dans ses oeuvres entre autres des
coquilles d'oeuf de cahiers de l'anacr
un espace didactique montre par le biais
de vidéos comment ces oeuvres sont
exécutés des créations contemporaines et
sensuelle mais aussi spirituelle et
symbolique
non
j'utilise beaucoup de symbolique dans
mes oeuvres et elle essaye surtout ces
deux des levées de sortir de la matière
le regard d'un 1
ce ne sont pas des pauses des oeuvres
posé ce sont 17 une exposition qui a été
construite au fil de l'exposition
l'artiste a voulu créer un sentiment
d'ascension vers la lumière avec les
escaliers les oeuvres passe ainsi du
plus sombre plus clair un travail ardu
et minutieux auquel l'artiste a consacré
cinq années avant de pouvoir présenter
son savoir-faire à découvrir jusqu'au 30
août
voilà monte à chiner xavier jaglin c'est
d'édition maintenant terminé merci de
votre attention rendez vous de
l'information locale demain à 18 heures
le journal sera présentée par wilfrid
richy bonne soirée